I've been to all the countries at least
once I don't buy out in in Asia there
was only one funny exception which i'd
like to tell a story about I was in
Bhutan three or four years ago and I was
being driven around in cairo by the
former head of the Museum in Cairo and
who was a high Lama minooka took 0 and
we were we my wife wanted to stop at a
store because she was looking for
fabrics and textiles to buy for a shop
at the Museum and this man had three or
four to Buddhist paint Bhutanese
paintings and I looked at there and I
said this one here is the 19th century
isn't it illegal to bring this painting
out of Bhutan he said yes but nobody's
going to open your luggage don't worry
about it and I didn't want to get in the
fight with him what would be the use of
it right and we bought the painting and
on the last day we were there I've made
an offering of the painting to this very
high Lama and former director of the
museum to to present it to the museum
and as thank you for everything that you
have done and he accepted it so
everybody in Bhutan that comes to visit
and we just did a huge three and a half
month bhutan show in New York everybody
in Bhutan you know the prince and the
Queen and only people know about that
story because i think it's the first
time that a westerner bought something
didn't take it out and donate it so we
were very proud of
there there is a very rich group of
artists not rich in the sense of money
but rich in the sense of good odd that
are painting and the museum I think
we'll have a show in a couple years but
that art is owned by my wife and myself
but I was last this past weekend I was
in Atlanta at a small school I went to
52 years ago called Oglethorpe which has
done show with the show on Himalaya not
even before to bet not even before I
knew they existed we've done a lot of
shows there and they have 43
contemporary Tibetan paintings and we
were there for the weekend I just came
back late last yesterday afternoon and
it's a spectacular show it's a
spectacular